[Music]
my name is Ed razik I'm the executive
producer of the show and the chief
creative officer for Victoria
[Music]
Secret the creative process for the show
is literally all year long I'm thinking
about next year today I think the main
challenge for anyone for any business
for any production is to do it better
next year I mean we don't sit down at
the beginning of the year and say this
year we're just going to do it a little
bit worse than last year we don't do
that you know it's what do we do next
what's better I mean this show is
dramatically better than last
year it cost $20 million to produce the
show this year it's so astounding
right I always get the question is it
worth it to spend so much money on a
fashion show well is it worth it to be
seen in 192 countries for an hour in
December and it's like uh yeah I think
so this show has made us wellknown
worldwide I want people to get off their
privileged butts because this is a hard
ticket to get and enjoy
[Music]
themselves